[Music]
in Millennials ruin everything use
know-it-all submitted by I bought you
using stead of friends alright we ruin
everything that sounds like a millennial
ooh yeah
Millennials are now being blamed for
killing casual dining restaurant chains
like Applebee's and TGI Friday good
because they suck it suck yeah unless
you want to sponsor us yeah hi Aniyah
everything sucks unless they want a
sponsor which they never do but I always
said this I [ __ ] hate chain
restaurants except fast we changed my
name's are good could they actually
taste good and it's cheap but these
chain restaurants they're just fast food
but you sit down and pretend that it's
expensive and you have to pay more money
but it's worse than fast food sometimes
yeah it's like what the hell yes a
granny what important about millennial I
am I hate them the only things I like
about them is when I'm on a diet and I
need to know my nutrition that still
list everything else they have it
because when I go to like a mom-and-pop
like a really nice restaurant they don't
know how much calories is in the lasagna
it's just the chef is like hi just
putting whatever you want in there but
if I go to Olive Garden I do know how
many calories I know is on you so do you
guys usually well I know Joe doesn't but
anyone happy you guys usually sit in
these like dining restaurants that
worsen champagne when I was younger I'd
never go there Danny was the [ __ ] when
you were a broke high school student and
there's nothing to do because you're
under 21 and they're hoping late I was
gonna say like I think it's a little
different no because like I always or
whatever is open to like latest like
what 10 midnight or something like that
like Danny's no or yet but I don't being
a morning [ __ ] fake though so it's
like Denny's is like the homegirl right
she knows she's ugly but she's like I
got gym black that I got in fact
Applebee my butt is the ugly but the
girl that's trying to be hot for you
like do I know what you look like
without makeup
Applebee's is that one ugly girl in the
group of hot girls that think she's one
of the hot girls but she's not through
the restaurant hot girls yeah that's
like a real restaurant with real state
houses real the ones that don't have
chains or they might have one in every
like major city but it's one
well let the expensive chick like chains
yes your TPMS three money son yeah like
Morton's Steakhouse or some boys how can
ya Ruth Chris yeah I remember taenia
those I mean I went to these types of
like like Applebee's or like Denny's
when I was just younger and to me like
just growing up just going to like
Chinese restaurants constantly are just
eating like food at home like eating
Deni they're eating alpha B's was always
like a tree because I was like oh this
is something so new my Co different but
then like growing up and like just
realizing like the food that they have
there I'm like mmm I kind of like going
to the Chinese restaurant other clothes
yeah I should get the sampler at Danny
oh uh chicken strips mm-hmm chicken
wings mozzarella mozzarella stick
everything's [ __ ] fried yeah and
somehow in high school you eat that a
whole meal in its own yeah another
six-pack that's so true amazing I don't
thank you Smith we mean no not there
anyways look at what's fair really
none of the days of him being able to
eat my [ __ ] and look like a hundred ten
pound Bruce Lee I would eat that [ __ ]
and complain that I can't grow remember
it's always do I I hope a morning trip
we saw always go all the time
what happened to that we're part of the
Millennials that are I like our via
business business oh they kill him
because they're no longer going pretty
much yeah is that because they were
complaining I don't know why I think
Millennials can continue playing yeah so
Millennials aren't going to these dine
in chain restaurants anymore so a lot of
these chain restaurants have been forced
to like shut down a lot of their stores
or restaurants because they just can't
operate anymore because no one's showing
up that makes me so sad I know what
though it's our taste buds
we're getting sophisticated it's that
but it's also because Millennials are
more attractive to cooking at home these
days especially with these subscription
services where
yeah you could just get all your food
delivered to your home they like the
convenience and ease and the fact that
everyone's like more like helps
health-conscious
so everyone's like well I don't know how
they're cooking my food I rather cook it
myself or they prefer ordering delivery
from these restaurants me and if it's
not that then it's the fast casual or
the quick serve kind of restaurants like
Chipotle and things like that that we
rather have because it's cheaper it's
faster we don't have to worry about like
you know the whole server experience and
things like that ah great that's a free
market though like you know you gotta
compete or you will die
Devin Spidey's so I don't feel too bad I
guess but just you're not offering a
product that I want to buy particularly
then Wow true millenials sorry or the
true capitalist yeah yeah because
they're saying that like even grocery
store chains has like jumped on the
delivery room again
you know like everyone's trying all
[ __ ] time I'm tired of going to the
grocery store said that [ __ ] to my Hymas
ons been doing mmm azan fresh you know
what the problem Amazon is what they do
over right away I'm tired of thinking
you daughter's picture is all about the
bin I gotta [ __ ] open my laptop
there's got to be like something where
I'm just like
and then there's [ __ ] three avocados
on my table but this is thinking though
well what you could do with my mind
somehow could click one button that says
order what I did last time but sometimes
I want to order new stuff
no you don't know what that stuff did
yeah order what I did last time or you
could have subscription so you order
once and you know like detergent that's
every month you're getting the detergent
right we just get order every month how
many can he buy dog food
I want a sidekick goes on cuz I think
about it and then they already know what
I'm gonna want and then I get like ice
cream at my house that's [ __ ] your
wife that's what my job is yeah you know
what you just need a mother yeah that's
what I did a good job because now I come
home and I'm like Ruby woo there won't
you be that circuit
I don't need any more I just realize
already have it I don't even think in
the should thirty there that's just
that's true I don't know how the house
gets clean but it is a come back home
cinnamon toast crunch mm-hmm
I just wish Amazon Prime first had way
more options because there's so many
times where I'm like I want this
specific thing but then they don't have
it on the glass to go to the store and
get it myself bok choy some ethnic gas
you know they don't have the ethnic
stuff no you know in 99 Ranch is
partnered up with it oh man ranch you
could get I could get my bruised
vegetables here oh yeah with the fly you
opened up at the Chinese grocery store
let it walked in my carrots not like
fish awesome the box is all soggy just
to give you the experience that's
awesome
and it was like a voice recorder yelled
at you y'all almost Oh once in a while
though I do enjoy going to like Costco
or the grocery store I just don't like
going on the weekends or like Friday
night or something because when you go
and everyone else goes it turns it into
like a big stressful anxiety event yeah
he's walking around like [ __ ] and
there's these lines and does all my gosh
at Costco that's when you have to plan
it out you get like another person with
you or actually bring two people one way
from the line well like one and we'll
the other person in you quickly get all
the items you guys already write out
your like your route and then you just
go ahead and never thought of a game
plan like that's too much work I usually
just go on my roller skates you should
go back you know why it is good though
on the weekend if you go there not to
shop on the weekends you go for the
sample yes yes
although I think the weekends have a
[ __ ] ton of samples do you don't even
have to eat at the food court my dad
would take me when I was little kid and
he would take my uncle dinner he's like
let's go to Costco why we're not getting
anything go for lunch you already know
let's touch a free loaded asian be the
Costco foods already like 125 it's free
you just need to walk and you get a
variety of things online your stuff I
find is way too much effort because
every time I go and I'm trying to do
that there's like a big-ass line yeah
you just have to reach back so now that
we've got a little bit of an antagonist
oh yeah I was way too much effort
nothin having to deal with like all that
crowd every time
like I don't go to Costco anymore period
but when I used to go and I would go
with Casey every time you come out like
you mean he's like [ __ ] hey Costco I
hate the people at recycle constantly
and having them I go around people with
big ass cards whichever one is a yellow
hammer and we also montebello one
there's awesome though they're both what
Helen's not you can't go to the Asian
ones because they don't know they drive
their carts like their cars but they
leave it like this may block both walk
yeah they don't know how to like move in
you know collaboration there's no flow
you got to go to the white people ones
yeah the lines are always like infinite
yeah anyways yeah these chain
restaurants are Diane and also saying
that they have adopted a lot of these
restaurants they're starting to adopt
the whole delivery thing where they're
creating their own delivery service
where they'll have to do a third party
and that's the way to do it man I think
the only way we can really survive right
now because like Millennials I want to
see them anymore but you know what
though is is it Millennials just sit
home all day being a lazy ass or
something different
because I feel like our generation is
working way [ __ ] more than the
previous ones I feel like a lot of
Millennials are creating their own jobs
I've never existed at all some things
are working away more though yeah yeah
if you're gonna work in a system and
then just clock in and clock out to
create something brand new and work like
20 prostate yeah that's so true man yeah
but they're direct competitors are the
fast casual restaurants totally open era
things with that I just like yeah from
from 1999 to 2014 the industry grew by
five hundred and fifty percent oh [ __ ]
which industry is fast casual industry I
believe it a hundred percent
you know the pokey restaurants they're
considered fast casual that's true
because like think about that that you
get it in bounce
kind of yeah because I think fast food
is defined by food that's already been
made delicious or something like food
that's already been made but then if
it's made to order then it's not fast
food anymore it's kind of like it's a
restroom it's a restaurant or fast
casual so then yeah I prefer it this way
though because I feel like um maybe it's
due to just you know Millennials
creating their own job working a lot
more but I'd like that I can deposit my
check via my phone I love that I can
order food via my phone like I don't
know it's so convenient its efficiently
I love it automatic payments we don't
have to [ __ ] like write the [ __ ] put
the they didn't go to the post office or
whatever damn effort on my 20 bucks move
my you later like that so convenient
[ __ ] love it no and I have moved into
my very first apartment and I was like
finally like so low grown up I wanted to
do that whole film I tried a little
crunches yeah I was trying to pay all my
bills with checks and like mailing them
out I did it once and I'm like this is
done how much good I got so bad like I'm
so happy yeah wait no this is easier now
you know what the real reason is we have
too many shows we gotta catch up with
our metrics on criminal on Amazon and
like we just have we just have too many
shows and movies that we got to catch up
with this generation has a hard time
speaking of other [ __ ] because we got a
lot of shows trust me a lot of good [ __ ]
to watch we do not a lot of good [ __ ]
too much and the game of Thrones is
coming out in a month so prepare your
[ __ ] hey guys hope you enjoyed that
episode please don't miss a beat and
subscribe if you don't subscribe you
don't know when a new video is uploaded
but for more videos click up here
[Music]